The Simpsons has some of the most
memorable gags,
John,
by the most memorable faces.
Why don't you just go down to moles and
talk to them?
I bet he'd be willing to share some of
his success.
Was he you with the most memorable catch
phrases?
Merge.
I'm too upset to eat.
Where do you go?
Go to Moe's
with almost 30 years on television,
the show remains a staple in American
culture.
So what's the secret that makes the show
so legend?
No.
Hey,
the secret is bounced.
We did
the simpsons had a comedic advantage
over every other TV sitcom at the time
because it was animated.
If it could be drawn at the Simpson
riders could make the joke,
they could do just about anything.
And that made for some hilarious gas.
No.
Well,
what makes the simpsons so great is that
the creators chose not to do just about
anything,
does the hardcore rule,
which is,
you know,
there's a lot of cartoons that,
uh,
where the impossible can happen,
you know,
and you think about a Wiley coyote
cartoon where he can literally blow up
and then come back and he's,
he's black.
And or he's flattened like an accordion
and they were,
it was always made very clear to me that
this is a real world and it gets
stretched.
Obviously it gets stretched like crazy.
Why purposefully hold back the cartoon
jokes.
Right.
Okay,
thank you.
That's the secret behind the Simpson
success.
Certain point,
it was like,
this is not a cartoon.
We're making a show that's not a
cartoon.
It happens to be a cartoon,
but it's not a cartoon.
Now we us young ones like the car goofy
cartoon jokes and as silly as we could
be,
but the slightly a whiz in the older
guys that know the approach it as a
family and it was,
as you say,
I think it's genius.
It's through the balance between cartoon
gags and realistic portrayals of family
life that the simpsons stands out.
This show had the heart and realism of a
family Sitcom,
but the humor of a cartoon take homeless
triple bypass surgery.
The episode has hilarious gags that
could only be done in an animation show.
Mr. Barnes,
I think he's dad
said to him,
to his widow,
eh,
no wait,
he's alive.
Oh good.
Canceled the him dope,
but the episode is just real enough to
have genuinely emotional moments.
Don't worry.
Marge America's health care system is
second only to Japan,
Canada,
Sweden,
Great Britain,
well all of Europe.
But you can thank your lucky stars.
We don't live in Paraguay.
It's a perfect
balance between what's real and what's
funny,
what I tried to is my life's work
is to bridge the gap between the,
the,
the funny artifice that I saw on tv and
what I knew was real.
And I think that's partly the success of
the simpsons.
The result is a show that's funny,
but also has this connect with the
characters.
What makes homer such a memorable
character is more than just when he's an
idiot.
The best moments in the simpsons are
when he proves he isn't a caricature and
he's actually a caring husband and
loving father.
Oh my little making.
They may never called you again.
Genki pants shows like family guy and
south park are really good at providing
social commentary and funny Gehrig's.
But these shows don't have the heart and
realism of the simpsons.
The simpsons has the perfect balance.
So whenever the simpsons has episodes on
a specific topic like politics,
marriage,
or religion,
the episodes typically have sincere
lessons along with the edgy jokes and
social commentary.
The Simpsons discusses these topics with
the perfect combination of humor and
sincerity.
Other animated cartoons focus more on
telling the most jokes as possible
rather than presenting a lesson and
other family sitcoms oftentimes shovel
corny message down your throat.
The Simpsons is right in the middle.
Take the episode.
Bart sells his soul.
The episode is not without its classic
Simpson's humor.
What every religion says there's a soap
bar.
Why would they lie?
What would they have to gain?
I don't care.
Strobing but in between the jokes is a
very interesting commentary on religion.
Bart sells his soul to mail house for $5
and he finds himself empty without it.
Unable to laugh at his pranks that you
usually bring him joy.
The episode actually has extremely
powerful symbolism when Bart without his
soul,
his left stranded in an ocean unable to
steer himself in the right direction.
The episode has a great wide shot of
bark protesting against spirituality in
the barren church.
With a heavenly light casting down on
him from above and an Erie Echo in his
voice.
Listen,
you don't have a soul.
I don't have a soul.
There's no such thing as a soul.
Through his spiritual journey,
he realizes the value of his soul.
The episode conveys the message that one
spirituality is not given by some church
or by anyone else.
It's created internally and the simpsons
gives all this philosophical thought in
a cartoon.
I'm not saying that the simpsons is the
funniest most of the matic or most
realistic show,
but what I am saying is that it is one
of the few shows to bounce each of these
three elements almost perfectly.
Of course,
the glaring unanswered question is what
happens just about every Simpson's video
on youtube has a top comment about the
shows decline in quality and while
people attribute many factors to the
decline of the simpsons,
like bad show runners,
bland storylines,
lacey writing or overused celebrity
cameo appearances,
I think the declines could possibly be
summed up by saying the simpsons lost
its balance.
A slate magazine review of the show sums
it up nicely.
Episodes that once would have ended with
homer and marge bicycling into the
sunset now and with homer blowing a
tranquilizer dart into marches neck.
Thank you.
Even in the new hd opening title
sequence,
we can see this subtle change in a show
that's more cartoon then reality.
Wow.
The majority of television shows never
maintain the balancing act,
the simpsons accomplished.
Although that's not necessarily a bad
thing.
Some shows are mostly to make you laugh
or mostly to make you feel,
and that doesn't make them bad shows,
but what makes the Simpson so legendary
is that they were able to have the
laughter and the heart.
Yeah.